[Music]
well hello dear friends uh so nice to be
able to speak with you in this program
I'd like to know thank you for joining
us as probably many of you know this is
a question and answer answer program
where you send us your questions and we
do the research and if there is an
answer we try to find it we thank uh the
Lord that you decided to join us today
and we trust that the program will be a
blessing to you and maybe answer some
questions that you've had in your mind I
have with me uh Pastor David Salasar uh
who is in charge of our Spanish
programming here at secrets on seal
among many many other things he's a jack
of all trades and a master of all and uh
it's really glad to have you uh Pastor
Salasar thank you Pastor B it's always a
blessing and privilege to share this
space with you in this time praise the
lord well we never begin without a word
of prayer ab and so I'd like to ask
Pastor Salazar to have a word of prayer
for us absolutely let us
pray heavenly father as we come before
you uh this hour to study your word and
to share from your word we ask humbly
that you will send us your Holy Spirit
to lead us into all Truth for we in
ourselves we don't have the answers we
don't have the knowledge but you through
your word through the Holy Spirit you
can lead us to all truth and so I pray
Lord that you will use us and speak
through us so that the answers May bring
uh Clarity and uh a real answer to those
that are seeking the truth and we thank
you for being with us and we pray all of
these in Jesus name amen amen by the way
if you want to send us your questions uh
you can do so at the following address
that you'll see on the screen
TVM tv.org once again
TVM tv.org
um please be patient because we get more
questions than what we can answer in a
short program like this uh but we will
eventually get to your answer uh to the
question that you ask uh so we have
several interesting questions today yes
and um the first one is um comes from
Serbia wow in Europe and uh it's from
spenco uh I guess that's the name
spenco p anyway this is a question Jesus
was very tolerant of people who did all
kinds of things against the
law while he was extremely intolerant of
one group in Judea the
Pharisees why can you help me to
understand thanks in advance well
actually can you help me understand why
Jesus was tolerant of many people who
were against the law like the adulterous
woman whereas he was very intolerant
towards the holy people so what can we
say about that well Pastor um it's an
interesting question and I have
appreciate that ESP Penco is really
trying to understand
this I guess interesting view on Jesus
which apparently he seems to be tolerant
to those that trans the law and
intolerent to those that would keep the
law but I would like to actually uh
answer from the word of God what Jesus
actually said for this particular group
of the
Pharisees uh one thing we have to bear
in mind is that Christ came to save
those that were lost those that had
fallen away and he made that very clear
several times he said it came to save
not the the those that are healthy or
well but I came to seek those that are
lost and so he actually came to show
mercy and kindness and love in redeeming
people from sin in saving them from
their sins but not necessarily to
condone their actions and in Matthew
chapter 23 when he spoke against the
Pharisees per se he actually starts
saying something about them that's very
interesting it says there in verse 2 and
three um the following the scribes and
the Pharisees sit in Moses seat in other
words they are sitting in the seat of
the
law all verse three all therefore
whatsoever they bid You observe notice
this carefully all that they tell you to
observe according to the law of Moses
that observe and do so Christ is never
telling you know the people that what
the Pharisees preached according to the
law of Moses was wrong as a matter of
fact he says you need to follow that you
need to fulfill the
law but he says do not ye after their
Works don't do after what they do for
they say and do not so the big problem
with Jesus with that group is that they
spoke highly of following the law of God
of following the Commandments of God of
being strict in the letter of the law
but in their hearts in their actions
there was not really that love for the
Lord and for fellow men and he clearly
exemplified that the problem with them
was not so much the teaching
but what their heart was how they
approached the experience of following
the law they tried to do outwardly but
never in the heart they never really
wanted to follow the lord in their heart
so this is where Jesus clearly defines
the problem with that he had with them
was that they will say something and do
something else but their teaching their
understanding what they would say in
regards to the law of God it was correct
and he said you need to do that as well
it's interesting that in the
gospels the Sinners and publicans felt
very comfortable in the presence of
Jesus M whereas the holy people felt
very uncomfortable right because they
knew that Jesus could read their
heart um the problem with the Pharisees
was with their heart right with the
inside the outside looked good but the
inside was rotten and Jesus compared
them to whiteed sepers yes you know I've
seen some imposing seers uh like at
Battle Creek where Ellen White is buried
right there's some maoams that are
beautiful white marble but what do they
have
inside dead bones you know I mean yeah
so and and in Matthew 23 which you
referred to um it contrasts the inside
with the outside see the Sinners they
didn't have anything to hide from Jesus
they were Sinners they were attracted to
Jesus because they felt that Jesus could
help help them right you know there's no
way that you can help someone who feels
that they don't need help mhm and that
was the issue that Jesus was dealing
with now um we have in John chapter 8
the case of the adulterous woman MH and
um you know they brought this woman and
they wanted Jesus to counsel them to
Stone her because she was caught in
adultery and um Jesus of course writes
on the sand he's writing the sins of
those who are present and then then he
ends by saying to this to this woman
something very interesting neither do I
condemn
you go and sin no more so Jesus isn't
saying you know these people that hang
out with me these publicans and sinners
they're okay the way they are no problem
right uh what he's saying is that when
you have a heart religion a heart
relationship with Christ then you're
going to go and you're not going to sin
anymore and by the way he said the same
thing to the blind man that he healed uh
in uh the story is in John chapter 9
right he said don't sin anymore L
something worse come upon you so Jesus
is not exonerating Sinners right but
Sinners come to him because they feel a
need and that's the reason why Jesus can
help them amen so it's legalism that
Jesus constantly in his ministry is
attacking absolutely and as you
mentioned Pastor you know it's not that
Christ was tolerant
for the transgression necessarily he was
tolerant of the people that needed to be
saved the Lord in his Mercy he wants us
to turn to him to to be safe from our
sins but he's not you know he doesn't
see sin or transgression of the law as
something that it's okay with he's not
okay with it he wants to save us from
that experience so it's not that he was
in favor of anybody staying in sin but
he was willing to save those that like
you mentioned came to Christ with that
willing heart with an open heart we
deire to be transformed and changed by
him amen forgiven uh so so Jesus loved
the sinner not the sin exactly some
people think that he loved the sin with
the sinner no he loved the siners ab and
he wanted to reach the sinner for
salvation amen amen amen for that yes
okay I hope that that uh helps in
answering this question uh the next
question really interesting I've never
had anybody uh ask this question before
it's regarding the the um grape juice
that is used for communion service do
you want to read that absolutely yes
Pastor it says I hope this message finds
you well I've been pondering a question
that has lingered my mind recently it
has come to my attention that certain
members of our congregation hold the
conviction that consuming processed
grape juice as wi during Passover might
not align with our beliefs I seek your
guidance regarding the true Passion Wine
considering our emphasis on promoting a
health conscious message is it
acceptable to use processed grape juice
this query arised arises due to the
general conference guidelines advocating
the use of Welch grape juice I am eager
to ensure our practice align
harmoniously with the gospel of Christ
your Insight on which form of wine
aligns best with our beliefs will be
immensely appreciated thank you for your
time and guidance that is definitely an
interesting question I never had that
question either um you know let's talk
first of all about Welch's grape juice I
think uh that that recommendation from
the general conference comes from way
back when uh Welch's grape juice was
about the only grape juice that was
available at that time and if my memory
doesn't fail me Welch's grape juice when
you look at the ingredients it says
grape juice that's it it doesn't even
have sugar yeah it it's it has natural
sugar of course it has fructose you know
from The Grapes but uh as far as I know
uh it's not processed you know lots of
sugar in it and preservatives and things
like that it's pretty natural um you
know Ellen White has an interesting uh
comment here in review and heral June 7
1898 uh she gives the requirements for
the bread and the grape juice and uh
there's no prescription in the Bible
about the kind of grape juice right or
the kind of bread just gives unfermented
grape juice and unleavened bread Ellen
White wrote the broken bread and pure
juice of the grape are to represent the
broken body and Spilled blood of the Son
of God bread that is leavened must not
come onto the communion table unleavened
bread is the only correct representation
of the Lord's Supper nothing fermented
is to be used only the pure fruit of the
vine and the unleavened bread are to be
used of course leaven ferments the dough
right and so I would say probably not
use sour dough exactly either for for uh
you know the communion service so the
only prescriptions that I know are
unleavened bread and un made grape juice
and preferably grape juice that is not
uh full of sugar you know where they add
sugar and preservatives and things like
that right it's a symbol that represents
the blood of Christ I remember in a one
time in the church um our Deaconess or
Hess had made a mistake in purchasing a
pure juice of grapes but it was not it
was from the white grapes so when they
came out you know when they brought that
Jew use on um for communion it was not
red it was more of a tan color and so a
lot of people were not happy because it
wouldn't really represent like the blood
of Christ and I could see some virtue in
that as well you know I think that is
important that the symbol closely
reflects who you know the blood of Jesus
and so this is why is better to have a
red uh grape uh that nevertheless there
might be some places in the other place
of the world where there's not that many
options and so you know we have to do
what is best within our means you know
if you find grapes and the grapes are
tend to be green or or white grapes you
have to do it with that you know so I
think that we have to be not so dogmatic
because it's simply as you mentioned
from the spirit prophecy and from you
know from the Bible as well you know it
has unfermented grape juice and I think
that the best the most pure is the best
way to go uh God takes into account the
circumstances of people right um you
know an analogous example is how how do
people in the North Pole keep the
Sabbath right Ellen White says they they
keep the Sabbath not by the position of
the sun but by the records kept and so
you know God take God does not say you
have to do it from Sundown to sundown I
don't care where you live you know God
accepts our best service when there is
no other way of doing it it's not like
naabu right they had Holy Fire
absolutely you know but they offered
common fire uh and I would say you know
if you have red grape juice use red
grape juice it's it's a more more clear
symbol absolutely of the color of blood
of Christ um but if you don't if you
don't even have grapes well you're going
to have to make some arrangement right
uh God is a practical God amen amen for
that yes okay well that was an
interesting question I had never uh
entertained that question before me
neither there's always a first time
exactly okay so the next question
uh if you want to read that Pastor the
next question has to do with the
ordination of Elders it says here um
I've been following your teachings on
the issue of woman ordination for many
years now thank you for your
Spirit-filled messages on this important
topic I am in total agreement with you
the current practice of many churches to
ordain women in the Royal office of
Pastor Elder is clearly not biblical but
I have a question on page 13 of your
third quarter 2015 newsletter titled
reflection San Antonio we stated the
following the fundamental problem is
that the decision to approve the
donation of women Elders was never voted
on by the World Church I am in agreement
here because as far as I can tell from
your my studies and research the GC has
had not done so up until 2015 and they
did not approve it at the 2015 GC
session so my question is this since the
2015 GC session has this changed has the
world church now voted to give local
churches conference unions or divisions
the option to allow women to serve as
Elders in their churches I think not
because I have not seen such a statement
in the 20th edition of the 7day
Adventist Church manual that was
published in 2022 did I miss something
did I miss a policy change by the World
Church actually not uh the person didn't
miss anything yes uh because uh the
ordination of women Elders has never
been voted by the world church and the
Bible is clear about the Elder the Elder
needs to be the husband of one wife I
mean it's Crystal Clear
um so what has happened well in 1975 in
the spring meeting right of
1975 uh there was a request from the
North American Division that there are
churches that are way off in the the
middle of nowhere they don't have any
men that can serve so would it be okay
to ordain women elders and it was
approved by spring meeting but with some
very restrictive
measures not just okay you can do it uh
in fact you know I'll show the the
article that I wrote and you can request
a copy from uh Secrets unsealed uh there
were some some really detailed uh steps
that need to be taken before a woman
could be ordained then in
1984 um a request came in once again and
some serious restrictions were placed on
it as well and uh it was approved uh
globally as long as those prescriptions
were followed uh to be able to ordain
women elders but you know usually what
happens is when uh annual Council or
spring meeting
approve something it refers it to the
next general conference session for a
vote
right the issue of the W ordination of
women Elders was never referred from
annual Council or the spring meeting to
the general conference session the next
general conference session so it has
never been voted by the World Church uh
to ordain women Elders um now we're at a
point where I think that there's to much
water under the bridge because everybody
everywhere is ordaining women Elders
without even following the prescriptions
that were laid down by annual Council um
and I believe that this is the root of
the problem this is a beginning of
ordaining uh women pastors because you
look at the Bible you know the
prescriptions that the Bible gives for
pastors and for elders are the same
right only the Elder serves locally and
the pastor with his credential serves
globally so uh in fact when we ordain a
pastor we use the same passage that we
use when we ordain Elders in the church
uh so it's never been approved to ordain
women elders and some people say well
Pastor boy you're fanatical I think that
we need to follow Church protocols uh
these something as important as the
ordination of women Elders really should
have gone to the general conference
session for manual Council I want to
recommend to those who are watching this
program that you get a copy of this um
newsletter that I wrote uh right after
the San Antonio General Conference uh
it's called Reflections on San Antonio
there's a beautiful picture of The Alamo
on the front and you can uh order this
from Secrets unsealed um I think it'll
be sent just for shipping and this gives
a whole history of women's ordination in
the in the 7th Adventist Church and it's
a real eyeopener uh it goes into what
happened at the 215 General Conference
session and what happened in 1975 and
what happened in
1984 so the reason why it's not in the
church manual is because only what is
voted at the general conference session
is included in the church manual that's
the reason why it isn't in because it
was never voted at a general conference
session it was never approved uh so uh
this person who writes says did I miss
something did I miss a policy change by
the World Church the answer is
absolutely not thank you Pastor wow
that's um interesting you know answer
because as as he probably is wondering
he's questioning whether or not there
has been anything done or changed now
it's disappointing in a sense and I can
understand his concern that there is a
lot of things that are being done on or
being um accepted as standard now
without really being part of the church
manual or the policy of the global you
know the GC session so it's something
that we have to encourage your friends
or those that are watching to really be
prayerful about and and you know to
approach the situation in a way where we
can help our leaders to turn back to the
word of God to the Bible to the manual
that the church has you know given in
the sense of following those protocols
that are there for the sake of the
church for the health of the healthiness
of the church to be able to really have
a a much more bible-based church and
that one that follows closely what the
Bible speaks of and I think that as you
mentioned the mistake is that we have
sort of deviated from Biblical Council
and accepted certain practices that may
seem as a answer for certain specific
cases
but they now have been approached as a
worldwide uh you know practice and it
really has put in question a lot of the
confidence in some places of leadership
and we have to pray for them you know
that they can maybe change these
aspects the problem is that we have
allowed
culture to dictate many things that we
do in the church yeah for example
there's all kinds of music that was
prepared for the secular world right
that is infiltrated into the Church mhm
it's not because uh people sat down they
said well let's study the
characteristics of good music and let's
com you know let's use this music
because because we looked at the Bible
and the spirit of Prophecy yeah no the
world has embraced this kind of music
and we've imported it into the church
we've Sanctified yeah the worldly music
the fact is that jazz and disco and Rock
None of these kinds of music were ever
composed for the church abolutely the
church has embraced them um you know on
page um let me see on page uh 10 of this
newsletter you have the the details that
need to be taken into account right in
order to ordain a woman Elder and um you
know when I look at this I'm looking at
it now I I wrote this article a long
time ago and I haven't really looked at
it since and but I say wow none of these
things are being followed in making the
decision to ordain women Elders they're
totally ignoring the vote of annual
Council uh and of the spring meeting and
so um you know I think that we need to
come back to the Bible absolutely
because we are on sure ground when we're
in the Bible when we're uh based on
culture and what everybody else is doing
we run into serious problems and Pastor
you know we are seeing the consequence
es or the results of those actions no
matter how much we try to publish good
news and you know reports to that paint
a picture of growth and progress at the
same time we're seeing a much more uh
worldly atmosphere in the church many
many young people are leaving the church
more so than ever and is not you know
doing any good to try to continue in
that path I think that like you said we
have to encourage leaders to turn to the
Lord and to the word of God sometimes we
think that by embracing the worldly
standard that the church is going to
grow yeah but uh meth the United
Methodist Church and other churches have
shown that it's just the contrary down
the road absolutely well uh thank you so
much for joining us for I'd like to know
today uh we appreciate your presence and
your questions please send them to us TV
at some tv.org God bless you hope to see
you next
time
[Music]